bentornato a Capire l'Informazione e il Calcolo Quantistico, mi chiamo John Watrous e sono il
direttore tecnico dell'educazione presso IBM Quantum. Questa è l'ottava lezione della serie ed è l'ultima lezione della
seconda unità della serie, che tratta gli algoritmi quantistici. Abbiamo parlato del modello di query del calcolo, inclusi gli algoritmi quantistici
che offrono vantaggi dimostrabili sugli algoritmi classici all'interno di quel modello; abbiamo discusso concetti fondamentali connessi con
gli algoritmi quantistici e come possiamo misurare il costo computazionale; e nella lezione precedente abbiamo discusso la stima di fase e l'algoritmo di Shor.
In questa lezione discuteremo l'algoritmo di Grover, che offre un vantaggio quadratico del quantistico sul
classico per i cosiddetti problemi di ricerca non strutturata, che descriverò una volta che entreremo nella
lezione. Questi sono tutti argomenti fondamentali riguardanti gli algoritmi quantistici. Esistono altri algoritmi quantistici,
nonché paradigmi generali che unificano diversi algoritmi quantistici e tecniche algoritmiche quantistiche, e
se sei interessato ti incoraggio a consultare lo "quantum algorithm zoo", che categorizza gli algoritmi quantistici noti e include molti riferimenti
a articoli di ricerca originali che hanno contribuito al loro sviluppo. Per questa serie, tuttavia,
ci limiteremo ai fondamentali, e a partire dalla prossima lezione passeremo a un nuovo argomento. Ma
prima parliamo dell'algoritmo di Grover. Ecco la panoramica della lezione: inizieremo con una breve discussione del
problema computazionale che affronteremo, cioè la ricerca non strutturata. Intuitivamente, puoi
pensare al problema della ricerca non strutturata come alla ricerca in una raccolta di elementi che non è ordinata e non è stata organizzata in modo utile.
Poi discuteremo l'algoritmo di Grover, un algoritmo quantistico che offre un vantaggio quadratico sugli
algoritmi classici, e entreremo presto nei dettagli di cosa significa esattamente. Una descrizione ad alto livello di
come funziona questo algoritmo è: prima c'è un passo di inizializzazione, poi un'operazione che chiamerò operazione di Grover
viene iterata un certo numero di volte, e infine avviene una misurazione che rivela un candidato soluzione
al problema di ricerca. Spiegherò cos'è l'operazione di Grover e come può essere
implementata su un computer quantistico, e poi analizzeremo questa operazione per capire meglio cosa fa e perché è utile per
la ricerca. La terza parte della lezione riguarda il numero di iterazioni
nell'algoritmo di Grover, ovvero il numero di volte in cui applicare l'operazione di Grover, presumendo di voler
massimizzare la probabilità che l'algoritmo riesca a trovare ciò che stiamo cercando, minimizzando allo stesso tempo il suo
costo. Inizieremo con il problema di ricerca unica, un caso speciale in cui c'è esattamente una soluzione al nostro
problema di ricerca, e poi considereremo cosa succede quando ci sono più soluzioni. Infine,
concluderò la lezione con alcune brevi osservazioni sull'algoritmo di Grover e le sue generalizzazioni. Cominciamo con
il problema computazionale che affronteremo per tutta la lezione. Come spesso facciamo, usiamo
Sigma per denotare l'alfabeto binario, e useremo questa notazione per l'intera lezione, quindi non lo ripeterò.
Supponiamo di avere una funzione f che mappa stringhe binarie di lunghezza n
nell'alfabeto binario. La nostra ipotesi è che possiamo valutare facilmente questa funzione:
ad esempio, forse abbiamo un circuit booleano per questa funzione la cui dimensione è polinomiale in N. Questo non significa che sia
necessariamente una funzione semplice in alcun senso, o che abbiamo una comprensione particolarmente buona di questa funzione. Ad esempio, forse abbiamo un
circuit booleano piuttosto complicato e disordinato per calcolare F che ci permette di valutarlo su diverse stringhe di input ma non ha necessariamente una
forma elegante progettata per semplificarci la vita. Il nostro obiettivo è trovare una soluzione, ovvero
una stringa binaria di lunghezza n che fa sì che F valuti a uno. In generale questo è un problema computazionale molto difficile,
o almeno sospettiamo che lo sia. In particolare, se l'input è di fatto la descrizione
di un circuit booleano per calcolare la funzione f, allora questo è un cosiddetto problema NP-completo. Un modo
per formalizzare questo problema è come problema di query, ed effettivamente per gli scopi di questa lezione è ragionevole
pensare a questo problema puramente nel contesto del modello di query. Ma quando pensiamo a dove o quando questo
problema potrebbe presentarsi in pratica, è probabilmente più naturale pensare a f come calcolata da un circuit booleano.
Come abbiamo visto nella lezione sei, possiamo però collegare questi due punti di vista attraverso la costruzione che abbiamo eseguito per prendere un circuit booleano e
convertirlo in un circuit quantistico per implementare un'operazione di query o un gate di query. In ogni caso, concettualmente parlando,
l'input al problema è questa funzione f e stiamo cercando una soluzione se esiste. Se
non c'è una soluzione, ovvero se F risulta essere la funzione costante zero, allora l'output corretto è segnalare
che non ci sono soluzioni. Questo è un problema di ricerca non strutturata nel senso che non c'è
nulla di speciale in F che renda facile trovare una soluzione. Non è come se stessimo cercando
in dati già ordinati o caricati in una struttura dati che facilita la ricerca, e non c'è nessuna promessa sulla
funzione f che potrebbe aiutarci. Un modo per pensarci è come cercare un particolare
numero di telefono in un elenco telefonico, al contrario di cercare un nome, che è molto più facile, presumendo che i nomi siano stati
messi in ordine alfabetico. In termini pratici, non si tratta davvero di cercare tra i dati,
che tendiamo a organizzare e archiviare in modo da facilitare la ricerca. È più rappresentativo della ricerca di una
soluzione a un'equazione complicata, ad esempio, o forse della ricerca della combinazione che apre un
lucchetto. Come inciso, ha senso pensare a questo problema nel contesto del modello di query indipendentemente da come ci sentiamo riguardo alla
rilevanza pratica di quel modello. Certo, nella vita reale non ci sono oracoli o scatole nere, ma finché non
scopriamo altrimenti, i circuit booleani complicati e misteriosi sono in qualche modo come delle
scatole nere. Ora pensiamo agli algoritmi per risolvere questo problema di ricerca non strutturata, e lo faremo
nel modello di query, solo per semplicità. Se abbiamo un circuit booleano per la nostra funzione invece di una scatola nera,
possiamo comunque eseguire algoritmi di query su di essa, ma ovviamente non possiamo escludere la possibilità che venga scoperto un nuovo algoritmo
per questo problema che non si basi sulla formulazione di query. Ma non ci preoccuperemo di questa
possibilità. Prima di tutto, una piccola notazione: il numero totale di stringhe di input alla funzione f è 2 alla
piccolo n, dove piccolo n è la lunghezza delle stringhe di input a F, e d'ora in poi userò N grande per questo numero, 2 alla
piccola n. È abbastanza comune che le persone usino lettere maiuscole come questa per denotare 2 alla potenza della versione minuscola
di quella lettera. Parleremo molto di N grande, quindi questo sarà solo più conveniente
e aiuterà a tenere le cose un po' più ordinate. Ancora una volta questa notazione vale per
l'intera lezione. Ora, ovviamente possiamo risolvere il problema di ricerca in modo classico semplicemente
iterando su tutte le possibili stringhe a N bit nell'ordine che scegliamo, valutando F su ciascuna.
Se troviamo una soluzione in qualsiasi momento possiamo fermarci, ma nel caso peggiore finiremo per valutare F su ogni singola
stringa di input, quindi questo richiede N (N grande)
query. Potremmo scegliere di misurare il costo di questo calcolo in modo diverso, non solo in termini del numero di query, ma il numero di query
rappresenta il numero di volte in cui dobbiamo valutare la funzione f, ed è ragionevole aspettarsi che le valutazioni di f dominino il costo
di questo calcolo. Questo è in effetti il meglio che possiamo fare con un algoritmo deterministico,
e ancora una volta siamo nel contesto del modello di query. Se abbiamo effettuato query su ogni stringa di input
tranne una, e F ha assunto il valore zero su tutte le precedenti, come possiamo essere sicuri che l'ultima
stringa non sia la soluzione? La risposta è che non possiamo saperlo, quindi abbiamo bisogno di tutte le N query nel caso
peggiore. Potremmo anche usare la casualità, che può offrire alcuni miglioramenti minori come ridurre il
numero atteso di query necessarie per trovare una soluzione quando ne esiste una, oppure potremmo in effetti scambiare la probabilità di correttezza
per una riduzione delle query. Ma comunque la si guardi, avremo comunque bisogno di un numero di query lineare
in N. Quindi classicamente abbiamo bisogno di un numero lineare di query, ovvero lineare
in N grande. L'algoritmo di Grover è un algoritmo quantistico per la ricerca che fa meglio: richiede solo O(√N) query.
Quelle query avvengono in sovrapposizione, quindi non è magia, ma è
un miglioramento significativo rispetto a ciò che è possibile classicamente, e questo è ciò che si intende per vantaggio
quadratico. Questo vantaggio quadratico del quantistico sul classico può essere trasformato in un vantaggio pratico
in senso concreto? Probabilmente non presto, ma nel futuro lontano chissà. Ma anche se
l'algoritmo di Grover non portasse mai a un vantaggio pratico per la ricerca, è comunque una parte importante
della fondazione degli algoritmi quantistici che vale la pena comprendere. Prima di passare all'algoritmo di Grover vero e proprio, dobbiamo
parlare brevemente dei cosiddetti gate di query di fase. Molti algoritmi quantistici nel modello di query si esprimono naturalmente
usando gate di query di fase, e vedremo che l'algoritmo di Grover è un esempio
specifico. Iniziamo con una rapida panoramica dei gate di query ordinari. Per una funzione f della
forma di cui abbiamo parlato, il gate di query UF è definito sugli stati della base standard come mostrato sullo
schermo, e per le sovrapposizioni di stati della base standard l'azione è determinata per linearità. Vale la pena ricordare
che a partire da un circuit booleano per f possiamo effettivamente costruire un circuit per questa operazione UF a un costo che è
lineare nella dimensione del circuit booleano. Il gate di query di fase per f, d'altra parte, che denoteremo con
il nome ZF, opera in questo modo. In particolare, questo gate opera su
piccolo n qubit invece che su piccolo n più uno qubit, e fondamentalmente dà automaticamente il valore della funzione
come fase invece di applicare XOR del valore di output su un qubit aggiuntivo come facciamo per
UF. Quindi se pensiamo a cosa succede quando usiamo il phase kickback su un gate UF,
stiamo fondamentalmente implementando un gate ZF. Abbiamo bisogno di uno stato meno e costa un'
evaluazione di UF, ma in effetti riotterremo lo stato meno e possiamo usarlo per il prossimo se vogliamo, oppure
possiamo semplicemente buttarlo via. Ecco cosa è un gate di query di fase. Ora, se ci viene dato
solo un gate di query di fase ZF e questo è l'unico modo in cui abbiamo accesso alla funzione f, allora non possiamo effettivamente
recuperare un gate UF. Ma se abbiamo una versione controllata di ZF, allora possiamo
costruire un gate UF, e lascio questo a te come
esercizio. Oltre al gate di query di fase per la funzione f, avremo anche bisogno di un gate di query di fase per la funzione OR a N bit,
ovvero la funzione che assume il valore zero quando le viene data la stringa tutta zero e altrimenti assume
il valore uno. Esplicitamente, il modo in cui ZOR agisce sugli stati della base standard è mostrato
qui sullo schermo. Questo gate non ha alcuna dipendenza dalla funzione f, quindi non richiede
nessuna query. Un modo per costruire un circuit quantistico che implementa questa operazione è fare qualcosa
di simile a ciò che abbiamo fatto per la funzione f, tranne che iniziamo con un circuit booleano che calcola la funzione OR su
N bit. Ora che abbiamo questi gate siamo pronti a passare alla sezione
successiva. Discutiamo ora l'algoritmo di Grover, iniziando con una descrizione dell'algoritmo. Iniziamo inizializzando
piccolo n qubit ciascuno nello stato più, ovvero mettiamo questi qubit in una sovrapposizione uniforme di tutte
le stringhe binarie di lunghezza n. Quello che faremo è effettivamente guidare lo stato di questi qubit
verso una soluzione. È intuitivo che iniziamo in questo stato perché non sappiamo ancora nulla sulla funzione f:
a questo punto ogni stringa è ugualmente probabile come soluzione, e ciò si riflette nel fatto che questi qubit sono in una sovrapposizione uniforme di tutte le
stringhe. Poi iteriamo: applichiamo ripetutamente l'operazione di Grover, che è davvero il cuore
dell'algoritmo e la descriverò tra poco. Applichiamo questa operazione un totale di T volte, dove T è un numero intero
non negativo, ma questo numero non è effettivamente specificato dall'algoritmo stesso: dobbiamo scegliere T in qualche modo, e nella prossima
sezione parleremo di buone scelte per T. Per ora possiamo pensare a questo numero di iterazioni T come
arbitrario. E infine misuriamo nella base standard, e questo ci dà un
candidato soluzione. Non c'è garanzia che sia una soluzione, ma se scegliamo T bene allora
la probabilità di ottenere una soluzione può essere resa grande. Ed ecco l'operazione di Grover
stessa, che abbiamo chiamato G. È una composizione di operazioni, tutte su N qubit, quindi questa è un'operazione a N
qubit. Prima abbiamo un gate ZF, ovvero un gate di query di fase per la
funzione f di input, seguito da uno strato di gate Hadamard, poi ZOR che è il gate di query di fase per la funzione
OR, e infine un altro strato di gate Hadamard. Quindi vediamo che un'iterazione nel
passo due può essere implementata da un circuit della forma mostrata qui sullo schermo, e qui abbiamo quattro qubit, tra l'altro,
ma in generale possiamo avere qualsiasi numero di qubit. Una cosa fondamentale da notare è che abbiamo bisogno di una query di f per implementare G:
abbiamo bisogno di una query per implementare ZF e nessuna delle altre operazioni dipende da F, quindi non richiedono nessuna query. Quindi questo numero T che
rappresenta il numero di volte in cui applichiamo G nel passo due rappresenta anche il numero di query di cui
abbiamo bisogno. Ecco un modo tipico in cui potremmo usare l'algoritmo di Grover, anche se certamente non è l'unico modo. Come ho già detto,
la prima cosa che dobbiamo fare è scegliere T, di cui parleremo nella prossima sezione.
Per qualunque T scegliamo, eseguiamo l'algoritmo di Grover per T iterazioni e otteniamo un candidato soluzione
X. Non c'è garanzia che X sia davvero una soluzione, ma possiamo spendere una query aggiuntiva per verificarlo. Se abbiamo una soluzione possiamo
restituire quella soluzione e fermarci; altrimenti possiamo riprovare, eventualmente con una scelta diversa di T
ma non necessariamente, oppure possiamo rinunciare e segnalare che non ci sono soluzioni. Come ho detto prima, questo
non è l'unico modo in cui l'algoritmo potrebbe essere usato, ma è un modo naturale di applicarlo al problema di ricerca. Ora vedremo cosa l'operazione di Grover
fa effettivamente allo stato degli N qubit su cui agisce. Pensiamo ai nostri N qubit come
formanti un singolo registro, che chiamerò Q solo per dargli un nome. Ricorda che ciò che facciamo prima
nell'algoritmo di Grover è mettere Q in una sovrapposizione uniforme di tutte le stringhe a N bit, e lo facciamo applicando gate Hadamard
a N qubit nello stato tutti zeri. Poi iteriamo l'operazione di Grover G e
misuriamo. Sarà utile partizionare l'insieme di tutte le stringhe a N bit in due insiemi: A0 e
A1. A0 contiene tutte le stringhe che fanno valutare F a zero, e A1 contiene tutte le stringhe che fanno valutare F
a uno. Un altro modo per dirlo è che A1 contiene tutte le soluzioni al nostro problema di ricerca
mentre A0 contiene tutte le non-soluzioni. Saremo particolarmente
interessati a due stati quantistici: uno è la sovrapposizione uniforme su tutte le non-soluzioni, ovvero |A0⟩, e
l'altro è uniforme su tutte le soluzioni, ovvero |A1⟩. Devo sottolineare che queste definizioni hanno senso
solo quando questi insiemi sono non vuoti, altrimenti stiamo sommando zero cose e dividendo per zero. E mentre svolgiamo
questa analisi dell'algoritmo di Grover, faremo quella supposizione. Possiamo capire molto facilmente cosa
fa l'algoritmo di Grover quando f è la funzione costante zero o la funzione costante uno trattandoli come casi speciali, ma lo lascio
fare a te. Non sorprende che, se ogni stringa è una soluzione, otterremo effettivamente una
soluzione quando misuriamo, e se non ci sono soluzioni non ne otterremo una, perché in quel caso non ce ne sono.
Ma ai fini di questa analisi assumeremo che entrambi questi insiemi siano non vuoti, in modo che queste
definizioni dei due stati abbiano senso. Tra l'altro, questa è una notazione abbastanza comune:
ogni volta che abbiamo un insieme finito non vuoto S possiamo scrivere |S⟩ per indicare la sovrapposizione uniforme sugli
elementi di quell'insieme, proprio come abbiamo qui. Raccogliamo quindi queste definizioni in questo modo e vedremo come si collegano
all'algoritmo di Grover. Il primo passo dell'algoritmo di Grover è il passo di inizializzazione, che mette Q in una sovrapposizione uniforme
su tutte le stringhe a N bit. Per dare a questo stato un nome facilmente riconoscibile, lo chiamerò
|U⟩, dove U sta per uniforme. Per l'analisi è importante notare innanzitutto che
questo stato uniforme |U⟩ è contenuto nel sottospazio generato dai due vettori |A0⟩ e
|A1⟩. In particolare, se prendiamo la combinazione lineare di questi due stati mostrata qui sullo schermo, otterremo
|U⟩. Ora la chiave dell'intera analisi è il fatto che lo stato di Q rimane in
questo sottospazio bidimensionale non importa quante volte applichiamo l'operazione di Grover. Quindi tutto si ridurrà a
cosa succede in un sottospazio bidimensionale. Vediamo ora cosa fa l'operazione di Grover, e in particolare cosa fa
ai vettori nel sottospazio bidimensionale generato da |A0⟩ e
|A1⟩. È utile immaginare che G sia divisa in due parti: una parte è il gate ZF
e l'altra parte è il gate ZOR racchiuso tra due strati di gate Hadamard.
Ecco la definizione di ZF come prima, ed è abbastanza semplice da quella definizione vedere che la sua
azione sui nostri due stati, le sovrapposizioni uniformi di non-soluzioni e soluzioni, è semplicemente mettere un segno meno
davanti a |A1⟩. Niente succede a |A0⟩, ed è tutto ciò che dobbiamo sapere
su ZF ai fini di questa analisi. Per la seconda parte, che è
il gate ZOR racchiuso tra due strati di gate Hadamard, iniziamo ricordando come è definito ZOR. Un modo per scriverlo
è come mostrato sullo schermo. Questa è la stessa espressione di prima, e un altro modo per esprimerlo usando la notazione di Dirac
è questo, e puoi verificare questa espressione pensando a come l'operazione sul
lato destro agisce sugli stati della base standard. In particolare, non fa nulla alla stringa tutta zero e ogni
altro stato della base standard riceve un segno meno, il che concorda con la definizione di Z
OR. Quindi se racchiudiamo questa operazione tra due strati di gate Hadamard otteniamo un'espressione simile, tranne
che al posto dello stato della base standard tutto zero abbiamo ora la nostra sovrapposizione uniforme |U⟩, perché H tensore
n trasforma lo stato della base standard tutto zero in |U⟩, e anche H tensore n è il suo trasposto coniugato, quindi funziona in modo simile
agendo da destra sul bra invece che sul ket. E ora capiremo cosa fa G ai nostri due vettori |A0⟩ e |A1⟩ usando i fatti che abbiamo appena
osservato. Iniziamo con |A0⟩: prima sostituiamo l'espressione
che abbiamo ottenuto per il gate ZOR racchiuso tra due strati di gate Hadamard. Poi possiamo usare il fatto che ZF non fa nulla
a |A0⟩ per eliminare l'operazione ZF, e ora usando la descrizione
di |U⟩ che abbiamo sopra insieme al fatto che |A0⟩ e |A1⟩ sono vettori unitari ortogonali, possiamo calcolare
il prodotto di questo bra con questo ket, e ciò che otteniamo è la radice quadrata del numero di non-soluzioni
diviso N. Possiamo usare questo fatto per valutare ciò che otteniamo, e sostituendo la nostra espressione per |U⟩ e
semplificando otteniamo il risultato finale mostrato qui sullo schermo. In particolare nota che questo
vettore è contenuto nel sottospazio bidimensionale generato da |A0⟩ e |A1⟩, come ho suggerito prima, e
inoltre i coefficienti sono numeri reali. Come sempre, verifica questo al
tuo ritmo se vuoi farlo. Tendo a passare rapidamente attraverso queste cose in questi video con
l'aspettativa che tu faccia una pausa per rifletterci se vuoi. Quindi facciamo pulizia in modo da
poter salvare il risultato finale per dopo. E ora faremo qualcosa di simile per il vettore
|A1⟩. Possiamo usare la stessa espressione di G di prima, e questa volta il gate ZF inietta
un segno meno, che qui si riflette nel fatto che abbiamo scambiato i due termini nell'operazione tra
parentesi. Poi procediamo in modo molto simile, e il risultato finale è simile tranne che i due coefficienti
sono scambiati e ora abbiamo un segno meno davanti a uno di essi, che è solo come funziona l'algebra. E di nuovo puoi
verificarlo al tuo ritmo. Nota che ancora una volta abbiamo una combinazione lineare reale dei nostri due vettori |A0⟩ e
|A1⟩. Facciamo anche qui pulizia e mettiamo insieme il risultato finale con l'altro. E ora possiamo vedere come G
agisce sul sottospazio generato dai nostri due vettori. Un modo per farlo è esprimerlo in termini della matrice 2x2 M
mostrata qui sullo schermo. Solo per essere chiari su cosa stiamo facendo: stiamo associando la prima riga e la prima
colonna a |A0⟩ e la seconda riga e colonna a |A1⟩. Finora in questa serie abbiamo
usato principalmente le matrici per descrivere il modo in cui le operazioni agiscono sugli stati della base standard, ma è comune usare le matrici
per descrivere le azioni di mappe lineari su insiemi diversi di vettori, non solo gli stati della base standard. E qui stiamo parlando di cosa fa l'operazione G
ai vettori |A0⟩ e |A1⟩. Possiamo dire di più su cosa G fa ai vettori nel
piano di |A0⟩ e |A1⟩ se esaminamo più da vicino questa matrice M. In particolare, ciò che troveremo è
che M è una matrice di rotazione, nel senso che la sua azione su questo spazio bidimensionale può essere descritta come una rotazione di un
angolo fisso. Ci sono un paio di modi diversi per vederlo, e uno è osservare
che questa matrice M può essere espressa come il quadrato di una matrice che sembra un po' più semplice. Potrebbe essere difficile individuarla guardando
solo M, ma non è qualcosa che dobbiamo scoprire da soli: dobbiamo solo verificarlo, e possiamo farlo semplicemente
elevando al quadrato la matrice a destra. Un altro modo per scrivere la matrice a destra, non includendo il quadrato, è
mostrato sullo schermo, e questo è il modo tipico per descrivere una rotazione di un dato angolo Theta come
matrice. L'angolo preciso della rotazione è il arcoseno della radice quadrata del numero di
soluzioni diviso N. Tra l'altro, poiché è la prima volta che lo vediamo, lasciami sottolineare che
questo angolo è molto importante: continuerà a comparire man mano che andiamo avanti con questa
analisi. L'argomento dell'arcoseno è un numero tra 0 e 1, e specificamente il modo in cui stiamo
interpretando l'arcoseno qui è come l'angolo tra 0 e Pi/2 che ci dà l'argomento quando prendiamo il seno.
Quindi questo è un modo di pensare a questa matrice che abbiamo elevato al quadrato per ottenere
M. E poiché elevare al quadrato la matrice è la stessa cosa che applicarla due volte, vediamo che M può essere scritta in alternativa come una
rotazione non di un angolo Theta ma di 2 * Theta, perché elevando al quadrato ruotiamo di un angolo Theta
due volte. Un modo diverso per verificare tutto questo, nel caso sia utile, è partire da quest'ultima espressione di M
e usare le formule per gli angoli doppi della trigonometria per ottenere l'espressione originale di
M. E questa è l'espressione di M che descrive l'azione che G ha sul sottospazio generato da |A0⟩ e |A1⟩, quella che sarà
più utile andando avanti. Tornando ora all'algoritmo di Grover stesso: dopo il
passo di inizializzazione ma prima di eseguire qualsiasi applicazione di G, lo stato del nostro registro di N qubit Q è |U⟩, la
sovrapposizione uniforme su tutte le stringhe a N bit. Abbiamo qui la stessa espressione di |U⟩ in termini di |A0⟩ e
|A1⟩ di prima, ma ora che abbiamo identificato questo angolo Theta vediamo che potremmo in alternativa scrivere
|U⟩ come cosθ * |A0⟩ + sinθ * |A1⟩.
Questo è chiaro per il coefficiente di |A1⟩, e per l'altro coefficiente basta osservare che la dimensione di A0 più
la dimensione di A1 è N, poi possiamo ottenerlo con un po' di trigonometria di base. Quindi questo è lo stato con cui
partiamo. La prima volta che applichiamo G ruotiamo di un angolo di 2 * Theta, quindi l'angolo totale diventa 3 *
Theta. Se applichiamo G di nuovo l'angolo aumenta a 5 Theta, perché abbiamo ruotato di un ulteriore
angolo di 2 Theta. E così via: dopo T applicazioni di G possiamo rappresentare lo
stato che otteniamo come mostrato sullo schermo, dove l'angolo del nostro stato è uguale a (2T+1) * Theta: 2 * Theta
per ogni applicazione di G, più un Theta aggiuntivo perché è lo stato da cui eravamo partiti.
Possiamo anche pensare all'azione dell'operazione di Grover in termini geometrici, e questo aiuta a fare luce su come
funziona e perché il suo effetto è di ruotare lo stato del registro Q. Ecco l'idea principale: l'operazione di Grover
è una composizione delle due parti che abbiamo già identificato: una è ZF e l'altra è ZOR racchiuso tra
due strati di gate Hadamard. Queste due parti sono
riflessioni, e quando componiamo due riflessioni otteniamo una rotazione. Vediamo come funziona in
maggiore dettaglio. Prima concentriamoci su ZF e limiteremo la nostra attenzione al
stesso sottospazio bidimensionale di cui abbiamo parlato, ovvero quello generato da |A0⟩ e
|A1⟩. Come abbiamo già osservato, l'azione di ZF su questo spazio è abbastanza semplice: non fa
nulla a |A0⟩ e mette un segno meno davanti a |A1⟩. Questa è una riflessione, e specificamente
è una riflessione rispetto alla retta parallela a |A0⟩, che chiameremo L1 solo per darle un nome.
Per capire perché è una riflessione, è utile disegnare un'immagine. Qui abbiamo i nostri due vettori
|A0⟩ e |A1⟩, che sono vettori unitari ortogonali, e possiamo pensare allo schermo come composto da tutte le combinazioni lineari reali
di questi due vettori. Il cerchio quindi rappresenta tutti i vettori unitari per i quali i coefficienti di
questi due vettori sono numeri reali. Ecco la retta L1, che è parallela a |A0⟩. E se consideriamo un
vettore arbitrario S su questo cerchio, l'effetto dell'applicazione di ZF è di riflettere rispetto a questa retta, come illustrato sullo
schermo, semplicemente perché non facciamo nulla a |A0⟩ e mettiamo un segno meno davanti a
|A1⟩. Nel caso speciale in cui S è |A0⟩, ad esempio, non succede nulla quando eseguiamo questa riflessione. E quando S è
|A1⟩, la riflessione ci porta fino a meno |A1⟩, il che è coerente con l'azione di ZF. Quindi ZF è una
riflessione che possiamo visualizzare come abbiamo qui. La seconda parte di G, che è ZOR
racchiuso tra due strati di gate Hadamard, può essere espressa come 2 * |U⟩⟨U| meno la matrice identità, come abbiamo
già visto. E di nuovo questa è una riflessione, questa volta rispetto alla retta L2 parallela a |U⟩ invece che a
|A0⟩. Possiamo visualizzare questa operazione in modo simile a ZF. Ecco il vettore
|U⟩ ipoteticamente, quindi questa è la retta L2 parallela a |U⟩, e ancora una volta l'azione su un vettore arbitrario S è di rifletterlo
rispetto alla retta, che è L2 in questo caso.
E infine, come ho menzionato prima, ogni volta che componiamo due riflessioni otteniamo una rotazione, e specificamente è
una rotazione di due volte l'angolo tra le rette di riflessione. Quindi disegniamo un'immagine simile
a quella di prima. Ecco le rette di riflessione, con l'angolo Theta tra
loro. E se prendiamo un vettore arbitrario S, lo riflettiamo rispetto alla prima retta L1 e
poi lo riflettiamo rispetto alla seconda retta L2, l'effetto netto sarà di ruotare il vettore S di un angolo di 2 * Theta.
Questo è qualcosa che è vero in generale e puoi provarlo su altri esempi da solo per vedere che è effettivamente così che
funziona. Ad ogni modo, speriamo che questo ti aiuti a capire intuitivamente perché l'operazione di Grover ha l'effetto di ruotare
i vettori. Passiamo ora alla questione della scelta del numero di iterazioni T nell'algoritmo di Grover.
Iniziamo pensando a come l'analisi che abbiamo visto finora, che rivela cosa fa l'operazione di Grover
quando la applichiamo ripetutamente alla sovrapposizione uniforme, si collega al compito che speriamo di risolvere, cioè trovare una soluzione al nostro problema di ricerca,
ovvero qualsiasi stringa contenuta nell'insieme A1. In breve, stiamo fondamentalmente per fissare
un obiettivo e poi capire quante volte applicare l'operazione di Grover per avvicinarci a quell'
obiettivo. Prima di tutto, immaginiamo di avere uno stato qualsiasi che è una combinazione lineare dei nostri due vettori |A0⟩ e
|A1⟩. Se eseguiamo una misurazione nella base standard su questo stato, otterremo un risultato nell'insieme A1, che è
l'insieme di soluzioni al nostro problema di ricerca, con probabilità uguale al valore assoluto al quadrato di qualunque coefficiente abbiamo per |A1⟩. E per il
vettore mostrato sullo schermo, quel coefficiente è beta. È intuitivo: se misurassimo lo stato |A0⟩
otterremmo una non-soluzione casuale, e se misurassimo |A1⟩ otterremmo una soluzione casuale. Quindi se misuriamo questo stato
otterremo una non-soluzione casuale con probabilità |α|², e una soluzione casuale
con probabilità |β|². Ma possiamo anche solo prendere un momento per calcolarlo. Ecco lo stato scritto
in modo da vedere le voci di questo vettore per gli stati della base standard. Quindi se misuriamo, queste sono le
probabilità di ottenere ciascun possibile risultato, e per ottenere la probabilità di ottenere una soluzione sommiamo le
probabilità per tutte le possibili soluzioni, che ci dà |β|²
come atteso. Abbiamo già analizzato cosa succede quando eseguiamo l'algoritmo di Grover per T iterazioni: otteniamo lo stato
mostrato qui sullo schermo. Quindi poiché il coefficiente di |A1⟩ è il seno
di (2T+1) * Theta, dove ancora una volta ecco questo importantissimo angolo Theta, vedremo
una soluzione con probabilità sin²((2T+1) *
Theta). Vorremmo rendere quella probabilità grande, idealmente il più vicina possibile a uno. Quindi mentre stiamo ruotando il vettore di stato
iterando G, penseremo a |A1⟩ come allo stato obiettivo e cercheremo
di scegliere T in modo da atterrare vicino a questo stato. E mentre lo facciamo, è bene tenere a mente che vorremmo anche
minimizzare T, perché è il numero di query che dobbiamo fare. Quindi se vogliamo rendere questa
probabilità vicina a uno e minimizzare T, ha senso cercare di rendere l'angolo del nostro vettore di stato vicino a Pi/2, perché
è il più piccolo angolo che rende il quadrato del seno grande. Quindi è fondamentalmente la prima opportunità di rendere la probabilità grande mentre stiamo
ruotando il vettore di stato. Ora, non possiamo necessariamente raggiungere questo angolo Pi/2 esattamente perché T deve
essere un intero. Ma se lo pensiamo approssimativamente e risolviamo per T come se fosse una disuguaglianza, vediamo che idealmente
ha senso scegliere T uguale a Pi/(4*Theta) meno 1/2.
Ma naturalmente T deve essere un intero non negativo, quindi quello che faremo è prendere
l'intero più vicino a questo valore ideale, che è il floor di Pi diviso 4 *
Theta. Prendere il floor, tra l'altro, significa semplicemente scartare qualsiasi parte frazionaria, ovvero è il più grande
intero minore o uguale a qualsiasi cosa di cui stiamo prendendo il floor. Secondo questa espressione, se il valore ideale si trova a metà tra due interi lo arrotondiamo verso l'alto, ma questo non avrà
alcuna importanza per
questa lezione. Quindi d'ora in poi ci concentreremo su questa particolare scelta di
T. Ma c'è un'altra considerazione importante che dobbiamo fare, ovvero che questa specifica di T dipende
da quante soluzioni ci sono, perché l'angolo Theta dipende dal numero di
soluzioni. D'ora in poi userò la lettera S per riferirmi al numero di soluzioni, ovvero la dimensione dell'insieme
A1, solo per comodità. Ad ogni modo, il punto è che la nostra
espressione per T, il valore che ipotizziamo sia buono, dipende da Theta, e Theta dipende da S, che è
la dimensione dell'insieme A1. Questo non è un problema se sappiamo in anticipo quante soluzioni ci sono. Ma
se non sappiamo quante soluzioni ci sono in anticipo, non sappiamo cos'è Theta, quindi non possiamo scegliere T in questo modo
e dovremo fare qualcosa di diverso. Tornerò sulla situazione in cui non conosciamo S un po' più tardi. Ma per
cominciare, concentriamoci sulla situazione in cui conosciamo quante soluzioni ci sono, iniziando con la ricerca unica,
in cui c'è la garanzia di una singola soluzione unica che stiamo
cercando. Ho menzionato il problema della ricerca unica come esempio di problema di query nella lezione
cinque. L'input è una funzione f da N bit a un bit, c'è una stringa a N bit unica
che fa valutare F a uno, e l'obiettivo è restituire quella stringa. Quindi
questo è equivalente al problema di ricerca non strutturata di cui abbiamo parlato, ma con la promessa che c'è esattamente una soluzione. E in effetti questa è
l'unica versione del problema di ricerca che Lov Grover ha considerato nel suo articolo originale del 1996 che ha introdotto l'algoritmo di Grover.
Per la ricerca unica abbiamo S uguale a 1, e quindi questo importante angolo Theta è uguale all'arcoseno
della radice quadrata di 1/N. Quando N è grande, questo valore è approssimativamente uguale alla radice quadrata di 1/N,
perché per angoli sempre più piccoli la funzione seno inizia ad assomigliare sempre di più alla funzione identità.
Se sostituiamo quell'approssimazione nella nostra scelta di T, vediamo che T è approssimativamente il floor
di Pi/4 * √N. Ottimo, perché siamo sulla strada di usare O(√N)
query, anche se a questo punto non abbiamo ancora esaminato esattamente quanto bene funziona l'algoritmo.
Vediamo un esempio in cui N grande è 128, ovvero 2^7. Quindi
la nostra funzione f va da sette bit a un bit, e assumiamo che ci sia una soluzione unica. Ma per capire quanto bene
funziona l'algoritmo dobbiamo solo preoccuparci dell'angolo Theta, che possiamo calcolare: è
approssimativamente 0,0885 radianti, che è un po' più di 5°. E se inseriamo quel valore nella nostra
espressione per T otteniamo otto. Quindi stiamo pensando a cosa succede quando cerchiamo una soluzione unica tra 128
possibilità usando otto query. Possiamo disegnare un'immagine per illustrare come cambia lo stato nel
tempo mentre eseguiamo le iterazioni dell'operazione di Grover. Come prima abbiamo gli stati
|A0⟩ e |A1⟩, e in questo caso particolare, cioè la ricerca unica, |A1⟩ è in effetti lo stato della base standard
corrispondente alla soluzione unica, qualunque essa sia. Ebbene, |A0⟩ è la sovrapposizione uniforme su tutte le
stringhe tranne la soluzione unica. Ecco la sovrapposizione uniforme su tutte le stringhe, che possiamo
scrivere come cosθ * |A0⟩ + sinθ * |A1⟩. Ha senso che |A0⟩ e
|U⟩ siano vicini in questo caso, perché come abbiamo appena osservato un momento fa, |A0⟩ è
quasi la sovrapposizione uniforme su tutte le stringhe: manca solo una stringa, che è la soluzione unica. Applicare G di nuovo ruota di un ulteriore
2 Theta, quindi ecco dove siamo dopo due iterazioni. Ecco tre, quattro, cinque, sei, sette e otto,
e ora vediamo che siamo abbastanza vicini a |A1⟩. Quindi se ci fermiamo e misuriamo a questo punto, è molto probabile che otteniamo
la soluzione unica. E in effetti in questo caso c'è solo circa mezzo percento di probabilità di non ottenere la soluzione unica.
D'altro canto, se continuassimo ad applicare l'operazione di Grover più delle raccomandate otto volte,
la probabilità di ottenere una soluzione diminuirebbe di nuovo, e nel tempo oscillerebbe mentre lo stato gira intorno
al cerchio. Quindi è importante che fermiamo le iterazioni al momento giusto se vogliamo avere successo con alta
probabilità. Pensiamo alla probabilità che la nostra scelta di T riveli la soluzione unica in modo più generale, per diversi valori di
N. Scriveremo P(N,1) per denotare la probabilità che l'algoritmo di Grover riesca a trovare una soluzione unica
per ciascun possibile valore di N. L'uno significa una soluzione, ed estenderemo questa notazione ad altri numeri di soluzioni
tra poco. Ecco una tabella di queste probabilità per piccole potenze di due. Inizia con N=2 e la
probabilità è 1/2, che non è molto buona. Ma per N=4 la probabilità è esattamente uno, quindi funziona
perfettamente in questo caso. È un ottimo esercizio, tra l'altro, esaminare esplicitamente come funzionano questi due casi,
in particolare il caso N=4. In quel caso stiamo cercando una soluzione tra quattro possibilità,
abbiamo bisogno di una sola query e funziona perfettamente. Man mano che N cresce vediamo alcune fluttuazioni: le probabilità
salgono e scendono un po', ma sembrano avvicinarsi a uno, ed è effettivamente così. Si può dimostrare
analiticamente che la probabilità è sempre almeno 1 - 1/N. Ottimo:
l'algoritmo non è perfetto, non siamo garantiti di ottenere una soluzione, ma è abbastanza probabile, in particolare per grandi
valori di N, nonché per la stranezza molto interessante che avviene quando N è uguale a 4.
Devo anche sottolineare che possiamo sempre eseguire l'intero algoritmo, incluse le misurazioni, quante volte vogliamo, e se una qualsiasi delle esecuzioni
ha successo otterremo una soluzione. Quindi se queste probabilità non sono sufficientemente buone, possiamo facilmente aumentarle semplicemente eseguendo
di nuovo l'algoritmo. In effetti, anche se queste probabilità fossero tutte pari a 1/2, avremmo comunque un
algoritmo di ricerca utile. Consideriamo ora cosa succede quando ci sono più
soluzioni. Inizieremo con un esempio simile a quello precedente: ancora N è uguale a 128, ma questa volta il
numero di soluzioni S è quattro invece di 1. Di nuovo possiamo calcolare Theta e T, e
otteniamo che Theta è circa 0,1777, o un po' più di 10°, e T è
quattro questa volta. Quindi l'angolo è circa il doppio del valore dell'esempio precedente, e T è la metà di quello che
era. Possiamo disegnare un'immagine come prima. Ecco dove
iniziamo: ecco un'iterazione, due, tre e quattro. Questa volta siamo molto vicini a
|A1⟩, e la probabilità di ottenere una soluzione questa volta risulta essere maggiore del
99,9%. Ma se non sapessimo meglio e pensassimo che ci fosse solo una soluzione, prenderemmo T uguale a 8 come
prima: ruoteremmo quasi tutto il percorso fino a meno |A0⟩, e ciò porterebbe a una probabilità di
successo molto piccola. Questo è un ulteriore esempio che mostra che ci sono buone scelte di T e cattive scelte di T, e qui vediamo
che una buona scelta per S=1 si rivela essere una scelta molto cattiva per S=4. Ma assumendo che conosciamo S in
anticipo e scegliamo T secondo la nostra specifica, si scopre che l'algoritmo di Grover troverà una soluzione
con probabilità almeno 1 - S/N, e spesso sarà molto più grande di questo. È anche almeno S/N, ma
questo è in realtà molto meno interessante. Ciò che è più interessante è che man mano che la frazione S/N diventa piccola il limite
sulla probabilità di successo si avvicina sempre di più a uno. Come ho già osservato più volte,
il numero T rappresenta non solo il numero di iterazioni dell'operazione di Grover che eseguiamo, ma anche il numero
di query che stiamo facendo. Quindi come dipende questo numero da S e
N? Prima di tutto, partiamo dal fatto che l'arcoseno di X è sempre almeno X, purché X sia compreso tra 0 e 1.
È abbastanza facile dimostrarlo se si conosce la serie di Taylor per la funzione arcoseno, ma ci sono altri modi per ragionarlo, e lo prendiamo
semplicemente come dato perché è vero. Ciò significa che Theta è almeno la radice quadrata di S/
N, e di conseguenza T è al massimo Pi/4 * √(N/
S). Questo è in realtà ancora meglio di O(√N): più S è grande in
confronto a N, meno query dobbiamo fare. E in un certo senso non sorprende che questa frazione compaia
così, dato che il suo reciproco definisce Theta, e alla fine Theta è davvero tutto ciò che conta per
questa analisi. Come abbiamo appena visto, l'algoritmo di Grover funziona abbastanza bene quando sappiamo
in anticipo quante soluzioni ci sono. Ma cosa fare se non sappiamo quante soluzioni ci
sono? C'è un approccio abbastanza semplice, che è semplicemente scegliere il numero di iterazioni
in modo casuale. Nello specifico, scegliere T uniformemente a caso tra 1 e il floor di Pi/4 * √N si rivela essere
un modo abbastanza buono per farlo. L'estremità superiore di questo intervallo è grosso modo il numero di query che sceglieremmo per la ricerca unica, e in realtà è
esattamente il numero giusto nella maggior parte dei casi: questo è quando l'angolo Theta è il più piccolo possibile, escludendo
il caso banale in cui non ci sono soluzioni. L'idea è che invece di puntare con cura il nostro vettore di stato verso
|A1⟩ come abbiamo fatto quando sapevamo quante soluzioni c'erano, stiamo fondamentalmente ruotando di un angolo casuale, come se stessimo dando
al vettore di stato una rotazione casuale. Se capita che ci sia solo una soluzione, la nostra rotazione casuale potrebbe spingere
il vettore di stato vicino a |A1⟩, ma potrebbe anche fermarsi a metà. E se ci sono molte soluzioni allora
la nostra rotazione casuale potrebbe potenzialmente mandare il vettore di stato più volte intorno al cerchio. Quindi non ci aspettiamo che questo riveli
una soluzione con una probabilità vicina a uno, ma la probabilità che ciò porti a una soluzione se ne esiste una risulta essere
abbastanza buona. È sempre almeno il 40%, in effetti. Non è ovvio ma è
così. Non è certo sorprendente, perché un angolo davvero casuale avrebbe il 50% di probabilità di trovare una
soluzione. Ad ogni modo, il 40% non è male, e ricorda che possiamo sempre aumentare la probabilità di trovare una soluzione
ripetendo il processo, scegliendo T indipendentemente ogni volta. Facendo questo, le probabilità di non
trovare una soluzione quando ne esiste una diminuiscono esponenzialmente nel numero di ripetizioni. Quindi se vogliamo una probabilità del 99%
di trovare una soluzione, possiamo eseguire questo semplice approccio 10 volte, ancora con T scelto indipendentemente ogni
volta. Naturalmente, se non troviamo una soluzione restituiamo "nessuna soluzione". Se non ci sono soluzioni
non ne troveremo, e quindi in quel caso restituiremo sempre la risposta corretta, che è "nessuna soluzione". Se ci sono soluzioni
potremmo non trovarne una e dichiarare erroneamente che non ci sono soluzioni, ma la probabilità che ciò accada può essere resa molto piccola.
Abbiamo anche, come ho menzionato pochi istanti fa, che questo richiede un numero di query o valutazioni di f che è O(√
N). Quindi usando l'algoritmo di Grover possiamo ancora risolvere il problema di ricerca con alta probabilità con O(√N)
query, anche se non sappiamo in anticipo quante soluzioni ci sono. C'è anche un approccio più sofisticato
che può portare a una riduzione del numero di query man mano che il numero di soluzioni cresce. Non lo descriverò in
dettaglio, mi concentrerò solo sull'idea principale. Iniziamo con T uguale a
uno. Poi eseguiamo l'algoritmo di Grover per un numero casuale di iterazioni, ma dove il limite superiore è T. Quindi la prima
volta che arriviamo al passo due eseguiremo l'algoritmo di Grover con un'iterazione, ma T andrà
crescendo. Se troviamo una soluzione la restituiamo e ci fermiamo; se non troviamo una soluzione aumentiamo T
e riproviamo. E a un certo punto, prima che T diventi troppo grande, terminiamo il processo e
dichiariamo che non ci sono soluzioni. È la stessa idea di base dell'approccio semplice, dove stiamo
dando al vettore di stato rotazioni casuali, ma qui iniziamo con rotazioni più leggere dove T è
piccolo, nel caso ci siano molte soluzioni. In questo modo non sprecheremo query facendo girare lo stato più volte
intorno al cerchio girando troppo forte. Ma se non funziona, ovvero se non troviamo una soluzione, riproviamo
ma giriamo un po' più forte, o potenzialmente un po' più forte. Per far funzionare questo, il tasso di
incremento di T deve essere scelto con attenzione, e un modo per farlo funzionare è sostituire T con il ceiling di (5/4) * T.
Quindi T viene aumentato esponenzialmente, e intuitivamente possiamo pensarlo come girare il 25% più forte ogni
volta. Ed è importante per l'analisi che T aumenti esponenzialmente in questo modo. Perché 5/4 potresti chiederti: ebbene, è
semplicemente un numero che funziona, e c'è in realtà un intervallo di valori che funzionano. Ma raddoppiare T, ad esempio,
è un incremento troppo rapido per sfruttare appieno i benefici delle rotazioni più leggere. Ad ogni modo, il punto di questo approccio più
sofisticato è che dà lo stesso limite asintotico sul numero di query che avevamo prima:
O(√(N/S)). Ma non dobbiamo sapere in anticipo quante soluzioni ci sono. E tra l'altro,
possiamo fermare questo processo quando T raggiunge √N. Quindi se non ci sono soluzioni raggiungeremo questa conclusione dopo O(
√N) query. Ed è così che possiamo scegliere il numero di iterazioni nell'algoritmo di Grover. Per concludere la lezione,
farò solo alcune brevi osservazioni sull'algoritmo di Grover. Prima di tutto, nel modello di query,
l'algoritmo di Grover è asintoticamente ottimale. Questo significa che non è possibile trovare un
algoritmo di query per risolvere il problema di ricerca, o anche solo il problema della ricerca unica, che utilizzi asintoticamente
meno di O(√N) query nel caso peggiore. È qualcosa che può essere dimostrato rigorosamente,
e ci sono in effetti più dimostrazioni note di questo fatto. È interessante notare che questo era noto anche
prima che l'algoritmo di Grover fosse scoperto: l'algoritmo di Grover ha raggiunto il limite inferiore già noto sul numero di
query richieste. Di tanto in tanto le persone propongono approcci che credono siano asintoticamente
superiori all'algoritmo di Grover, ma c'è sempre o un errore, o un'ipotesi sulla funzione f e
su come può essere accessa, o qualche altro problema che rende la pretesa errata. Se lavori correttamente
nel modello di query, non puoi battere l'algoritmo di Grover per la ricerca non strutturata. Secondo, l'algoritmo di Grover è
ampiamente applicabile nel senso che il miglioramento della radice quadrata che offre per il problema di ricerca non strutturata può essere
ottenuto in una varietà di contesti diversi. Ad esempio, a volte è possibile usare l'algoritmo di Grover sopra
un altro algoritmo per ottenere un miglioramento quadratico oltre le prestazioni di quell'algoritmo. L'algoritmo di Grover è anche
abbastanza comunemente usato come subroutine all'interno di altri algoritmi quantistici. Come semplice esempio, possiamo
usare l'algoritmo di Grover per ottenere un vantaggio quadratico sugli algoritmi classici per il problema del minimo di cui ho parlato nella
lezione cinque. E infine, la tecnica usata nell'algoritmo di Grover, in cui abbiamo due
riflessioni composte e iterate per ruotare un vettore di stato quantistico, può essere generalizzata in modo
abbastanza significativo. Un esempio è una tecnica nota come amplificazione dell'ampiezza, in cui un processo
che generalizza l'algoritmo di Grover può essere applicato a un altro algoritmo quantistico per aumentarne essenzialmente la probabilità di successo in modo quadraticamente più veloce di
quanto sarebbe possibile classicamente. E quella tecnica ha ampie applicazioni negli algoritmi quantistici. Quindi potrebbe essere vero che
l'algoritmo di Grover probabilmente non porterà a un vantaggio quantistico pratico presto, se mai lo farà. Ma l'algoritmo di Grover è
senza dubbio un algoritmo quantistico fondamentalmente importante e ampiamente applicabile, ed è rappresentativo di una tecnica più generale che ha molti
usi. Ed è tutto per questa lezione e per questa unità della serie, che è stata sugli algoritmi quantistici.
Abbiamo discusso il modello di query e come possiamo collegarlo a un modello di calcolo più standard, insieme
ad altri concetti fondamentali su come possiamo misurare il costo computazionale. Abbiamo poi trattato la stima di fase,
la fattorizzazione e infine l'algoritmo di Grover. Come ho già suggerito,
c'è molto altro da imparare sugli algoritmi quantistici, ma in questa serie passeremo a un diverso argomento nella prossima unità. In particolare, daremo uno
sguardo alla formulazione generale dell'informazione quantistica, in cui gli stati quantistici sono rappresentati da matrici di un certo
tipo, note come matrici densità. Come vedremo, questa formulazione si rivela molto utile e in effetti
essenziale per comprendere alcuni aspetti dell'informazione quantistica, ed è anche abbastanza bella da un punto di vista
matematico. Spero quindi che ti unisca a me per l'unità tre, e arrivederci.
A presto.